the colors you choose the materials you
pick all that tells the stories of the
world who you are to look at something
as inspiration it's always good to kind
of draw on everything that you've
experienced and they make it your own
before I even say word to you my
personal style says everything that I
need to say about myself
it's important to articulate your
personal message through your aesthetic
what defines you what's important to you
what you show and what people see I
always like the concept of simple yet
severe it's really about having certain
statement pieces I wanted like the main
things he always says about himself
simply yet severe clean Americana but
like with a updated twist on it
my brother style I think it's a lot of
times it's pared down but there's a few
pieces that really stand out the main
thing for me is am i comfortable in it
that's not just physically comfortable
but comfortable what it's saying to
everybody else so the way you look the
style is you create kind of tells that
story whether indirectly or directly
whether looking back on time or look in
the future always feeling like it's me
and it's unique and it's authentic
like really neutral color t-shirts jeans
two gold chains big beard this is the
way that I want to be understood this is
the person that I am and I'm not gonna
compromise that I'm Adam Golson I'm an
entrepreneur I'm the co-founder of
athletic propulsion labs my name is Ron
Bolton I'm all entrepreneur and I'm the
co-founder of athletic propulsion labs